[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the squad ride presented by
bleacher report are presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
at
uh super bowl sunday we clap for
ourselves because we're excited
we made it to the final weekend of the
season and today will determine kelly's
mood for the next seven months
my name is katie richards our vetting
expert and who secures the bag every
week is kelly stewart and
a man who built an army inside of the
squad
that is greg ivory look um we've been on
anytime touchdowns on this show we need
to salute the all world
all-pro devante adams thank you thank
you for the touchdown in the nfc
championship game
and great pick uh ole mic legend riley
sorgo
we are 15 and five on the year we're our
winning percentage is
7.50 we're just crushing it so thank you
very much uh davonte adams
um today's the final squad ride of the
year
kind of sad but it's exciting at the
same time and but before we get into the
show we have a huge show ahead
we want to celebrate your wins and a
bunch of the legendary locks that you
guys sent us
enjoy how's it going today br ready
in order to be the best you gotta pick
the best wedding god
send me a sign
[Music]
squad ride pick them oh my god
david cameron chop baby
dalvin cook vikings
winners only please you heard it here
first
so many legends in one clip we enjoyed
those wins and please
enjoy these hoodies from the general of
generosity
cabbie you heard her you heard her they
ended the video with it
winners only please this is the handy
dandy ipad right here where i am looking
for winners
only please and some good takes because
i'm giving away some hoodies
cabbie kelly i am in the comments
i got my guy toe tonton miles sam mccole
hartman tonight
the score touchdown shouts out to you
tom tom you're walking away with a
hoodie
i got a couple more cabbie s ross 30
says gronk he's rocking with gronk
to get in the end zone today shouts out
to us ross
you're walking away with hoodie uh
raider4life13 says tv12 will show it
show you guys how it's done he said he's
the goat he's gonna show us how it's
done today
hey i cannot wait for this cabbie if tom
brady shows us how it's done today
forget it he's the legend he he's the
goat although he's already the goal but
it's like
we can't even talk about it like it's
nothing to talk about if he shows us
today
hey look he he started the season with
tampa with a little qb keeper for a
touchdown
hey anything's possible in super bowl 55
in fact
let's take a look we asked on social
earlier this week who's a lot to score
touchdown in the big game
let's take a look at these players and
tom brady is on the board
right down there at plus 400 listen
anything is possible and
all of actually all of these players can
score touchdowns today
that's how juicy this menu is uh today's
show we're going to show you our top
three or
show you your top three pitches from
this week and let you decide
the squad ride so let's get started our
first pitch comes from tom santangelo
and his good friend lily
okay she's sniffing the mouse she's
already sniffing the mouse she's has her
eyes on one of them
she's going for the anytime touchdown oh
we got a drawer
she's got a little camera underneath
what's it who's it going to be
mike evans anytime touchdown you heard
it hear french friends
mike evans great pick and just like lily
i too will be carb loading on a super
bowl sunday our next
uh pitch comes from a guy who knows a
guy who is the guy
il legenda nikki cass
hey how's everybody doing today did you
miss me
i got some for you guys do you want to
pick from pacquiao
anytime touchdown score you know i gave
you java camaro last time and what
happened
hey thanks bye squat no problem but boy
do i have something for you for the
super bowl give me a second here
okay yeah could i give you an easy one
of course
but i gave you an easy one last time i'm
here to tell you right now
patrick mahomes is crossing into the end
zone on super bowl sunday
wow what are you doing i'm making you
money that's what i'm doing
bet the house honey god bless
bet the house are we betting that we've
been mortgages now
uh nice work man patrick mahomes versus
mike evans
gmody what'd you think of these pitches
cabbie we got
mike evans patrick mahomes we got
bunnies
we got ill magenta uh i need you guys to
do me a favor i need you guys you guys
know i'm all about the bunnies i need
bunnies in the comments right now i need
bunnies in the comments right now shout
out to mike evans
uh he tom brady might
find him today cabbie mike tom brady
might find him in the end zone
but i did i mean i did call this last
week the patrick mahomes
touchdown scrolling right pylon dive
you know what i'm saying i i i'm feeling
the vibes there
but uh kelly kelly kelly you know
value you know numbers talk to us what
are we which way are you leaning we got
mike evans patrick mahomes
you know this is tough because i do
agree with you i think
i think patty mahomes will get in the
end zone plus 240
with the odds boost we just got to bet
that by itself
and as far as mike evans goes in theory
mike evans should score a touchdown but
let's talk about all of the other
weapons that tom brady has
he's got guys that i had to google
during the packers game and figure out
how i lost
my first half under for i still implored
by that one thank you kevin king
okay sorry i had to get through my
therapy session real quick but
mike evans patrick mahomes i like
patrick mahomes here
yeah kevin king is he he he was
he got cooked and he was lit up on
twitter sorry g money because we know
that's your homie
yeah that's the that's the homie that's
the homie but hey cabby i'm
i'm doubling up i got my phone i got the
handy dandy and all i see is bunnies
literally all i see is bunnies and
that's what i love because it's bunnies
and sunsets here for the vibes i'm
giving away hoodies
b grin b grin six seven three
nine seven says patrick mahomes i like
that pick so i'm
rocking with him giving away a hoodie uh
here we go alley
10 24. he got the bunny gift cabbie
hopefully it doesn't go away you guys
see the bunny right there
got the bunny gift shouts out to you i
see a lot of bunnies we got
melissa melissa melissa mccormick it was
eating cabbie
it was it was eating yeah melissa
mccormick shouts out to you you're also
walking away with a hoodie
i got shimmy burger he's a he's a he's
one of uh those squad ride favorites
shouts out to you shimmy breaker
burgers uh enderman enderman shouts out
to you he gave us a gift cabbie he's
he's rocking with the bunnies cabbie it
is a parent
i'm just going to make the call i'm
going to make the call roll tide roll
underscore tied shouts out to you i'm
going to give you a hoodie
cathy i'm making the call the the
comments is taken over with the bunnies
the comments the bunnies have taken over
the comments
uh we are riding we're riding with mike
evans moving on to the next round okay
excellent so mike evans
and uh tom santangelo congratulations
lily
you got the squad into the final round
okay because listen
we have a packed show so this mat this
next matchup is our final matchup of the
squad ride and whoever
you guys pick is our squad ride but we
have a few surprises down the line
so our next matchup uh come our next
pitch comes from
the snack legend formerly the alexa
legend
spencer freeman
[Music]
hey you gotta go with the big bowl of
snacks for the big game travis kelsey
and mike evans is our final match up uh
g-money what'd you think of that video
that video makes me hungry kathy that
video actually makes me hungry
actually i need everybody in the
comments right now
to put up a gift send in a comment of
what you're going to be eating during
the super bowl i need the comments full
of what you're going to be eating during
the super bowl
get in the comments let me know right
now uh
travis kelsey i'm loving it though minus
162 you know what we can do here
i mean even with the mike evans plus 100
you know what we can do here
we change that make it to uh plus 300
uh i do think travis kelsey
um is gonna have a big game today you
know pat loves to find kelsey
cabbie kelly you know last year don't
even talk about it
anyway kelly talk to me mike
evans travis kelsey
what sway are you in you're right we
have to go with travis kelsey here
i always talk about him he's not a tight
end he's a big body wide receiver he
makes
big body plays because it's really hard
for those defensive backs
to be able to tackle my dude and with
tyrique hill getting double-teamed all
day i think that leaves
a spot for kelsey to be open we know
that patrick mahomes likes to find him
in the back of the end zone i think
that's exactly what's gonna happen here
i like kelsey in this one
good picks by our audience so far
patrick holmes scored a touchdown last
year and travis kelsey also scored a
touchdown last year
likely to do it again this year uh get
in the comments tell g-money which way
to lean
mike evans or travis kelsey and who
should we ride with
listen um kelly in an effort to run it
back the kansas city chiefs are going to
rely on their explosive
offense last year you leaned kc minus
one and a half it covered
you also leaned the game to go under the
53 and a half
it covered so this year kelly kells are
you leaning
are you running it back with the kansas
city chiefs as your best bet
yes in a way cabbie i do lean towards
the under here i think that's the play
and i think
that's exactly where i'd love to go but
i just can't do it
you know what was the best thing last
year i'm sitting there on the couch with
greg
i'm sitting there on the couch with west
we got the niners we got the chiefs
they're hating each other the whole game
the chiefs go down 10 and i look at west
and i say west
we got plus 240 in game what do you
think buddy and we hammer the chiefs in
game
and since that moment i have not bet the
chiefs pre-flop
i wait for him in game a couple weeks
ago best bet chiefs minus three i said
hey
you guys might find better value in game
they go down nine to the bills and what
happened
if you like the chiefs you should be
waiting to bet them in game
this is a four teen and two team
16 and two if you're counting the
playoffs but
they have been atrocious against the
spread i can't bet them against the
spread so i'm taking the chiefs
on the money line in game and as far as
my best prop that goes if
hopefully you're paying attention on the
ig story yesterday tom brady to throw in
the reception i don't want to hear it
from
all the people that i'm a tom hater i
think this is actually going to be a
really good game
i can see this being like a 28 27 type
game
lands on 55 everybody loses their mind
kansas city gets the win and everybody
the vet tampa bay moneyline
is upset well uh a smart
smart person once said that you never
get bet against tom brady and an even
smarter person said
father time is undefeated so we're
listening and we're looking at you
uh honey badger snead breeland all you
boys
in the in the kansas city secondary tom
brady to throw an interception
lock it in uh all right uh g-money i'm
sure the um
the comment section is loaded with a
bunch of animal gifts or a bunch of
animal emojis
totally hopefully there are uh one or
two names in there either mike evans or
travis kelsey let us know my g
who we are riding with on a super bowl
sunday cabbie i see
food everywhere i see my fries right
i see fries shouts out to ross ross on
klim
you're walking away with hoodie he he he
got fries for us
i got uh mf wing time four says cheesy
potatoes kelly what do you know about
those cheesy potatoes
potatoes on the super bowl listen i'm a
chips and dip kind of girl like i want
like eight different dips
all the different chips some crackers
some cheese some charcuterie some wine
well
anyway hey hey i got moody moody baby
says
a honey not a hundred cabbie uh honey
honey
honey wings he ordered a haunted wing
shouts out to you moody
uh having a party hey cabbie and you
know what all these gifts
all these gifts uh of food i got travis
kelsey gifts
mixing in team wolfy shouts out to you
he got the travis kelsey time to eat
gift going right there you guys see it
that's travis right there
uh i got travis kelsey dancing what
shouts out to you juan
juan pellet there you go right there
cabbie i'm making the call
that's it i'm making the call let me
give away one more hoodie southpaw 88
shout out to you
all right here we go cavi it is
apparent we are riding we are riding
with
travis kelsey to score a touchdown two
day
can we let's get into the graphic can we
pull up the graphic please so i can show
you guys a little bit of magic
a little bit of magic that we do here
you see travis kelsey it says minus 162.
poof you guys saw that right you guys
saw that
shout out i mean this is the magic show
right here baby plus
300 shout out to draftkings man we only
do that here make sure you guys come on
over to the br
instagram story where we will be riding
with travis kelsey to score a touchdown
cabbie gave our record i mean if you're
not riding you're losing like what
but remember baby but remember cabbie
remember
you guys drop it in the comments i need
you guys to drop the saying in the
comments
right now let's go uh g-money do you
know if magic city
uber eats wings because i'm interested
in some lemon pepper
like in the atlanta metro area for sure
ubereat that's what i was gonna say
you're in vegas bro
hey i'll see what the spearmint rhino
can do i don't think they have wings but
they have chicken fingers
ah yes some entertainment and some more
entertainment on a on a super bowl
sunday okay
so uh listen our show's not over this is
generally the time
where we end the squad ride but it's hey
it's the big game so we have a bigger
show
um if you guys caught our our drop zone
uh episode chad ocho cinco johnson was
leaning heavy on tyrique evans to have a
huge day
so we asked him who would win a foot
race cheetah
or ochocinco chad johnson in his prime
tyree killing his prime who wins a foot
race what race
now yeah at the finish line is there
mcdonald's
there is mcdonald's yes i definitely win
i don't care who i'm running against
i don't know it doesn't matter i'd love
to see it
excuse me of course i meant tyreek hill
not uh tyree gibbons that's my bad
um so uh listen there are some high
performances that are
fueled by or propelled by jet fuel or
gatorade for chad johnson
it's mcdonald's we still don't get it he
is a marvel of science
um and the tampa bay defense is going to
get all it can handle with
uh tyreke hill today so let's take a
look at this menu that draftkings is
offering
a bunch of tie rekill props this is
outstanding like
this dude can hit all of these you know
he is he is that talented and the most
exciting player
on the field like reception yards over
95 and a half
first touchdown is really juicy the mvp
odds are really juicy
chad johnson is a legend tyrek hill is a
future legend
and what we have for you now is ocho
singles
legendary lock yo with chad johnson look
very important i have five prop bets for
tyra kill
for tonight's game against the bucks the
first one
first reception second private retiree
kill
reception over third prop bet every kill
reception yards over
fourth first td
likely it's probably tyre tyraquil
anytime td now let's shake these up
hoping for a little love and the problem
that we are going to use for tonight is
deceiving yards over lock it in
bet it kind of kill receive yards over
mcdonald's i love you thank you
good morning even though
mcdonald's is delicious i think i like
the biggie smalls
uh sweatshirt more than more than the
mcdonald's
uh listen kelly last year tyrikill
caught nine passes
for 105 yards are you going are you
leaning tyrek hill
over 95 and a half tonight i don't know
kathy but i got to get you some in and
out you've lived in vegas for way too
long
to make that terribly egregious comment
there uh all jokes aside we know chad is
a mcdonald's king but we also know
that he's like bffs with ty reek so like
maybe he got some inside info but he
told us on the drop zone show
that he thought tyrique was going to be
double teamed all day long
look i took patrick mahomes under
passing yards and i know i got a lot of
grief for that but the price was just
too high i believe the
the same is for tyrek hill's receiving
yards i do think he's going to be double
teamed
yes there is a good possibility i could
get absolutely smoked on one
big yardage play by tyreek but i'm going
to take the under
95 and a half yards g-money tell me that
the comments are now flooded with
cheetah gifs
or cheetah emojis kevin comments are all
over the place i see a whole bunch of
winners only please shout out to you
guys
adam012 shouts out to you and i also see
uh
see chad johnson gifts i see uh
one cheetah gift smooth turn two shouts
out to you
uh comments once again are all over the
place i see
i see you winners only please marvin
shouts out to you barbin
cabbie um the comments i see chadocho
cinco chad ocho cinco
si chadocho cinco a lot i'm gonna give
away some more hoodies dinah slugger
chatto cho cinco shouts out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie i got
one more in me cabbie
milwaukee 1919 he says
uh the comment went away but it was
something about chad shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie
we love chad and we we are uh dying with
anticipation to see how tyreek hill
performs today
um listen we have one last bit of action
before the buffalo wings are delivered
uh g-money tell the squad what's up
cabbie we've given a lot of love to the
big names this year
the devontas the alvin's the lamars
but sometimes uh it's the little guys
that do big things so today we're taking
an
underdog prop yes cabbie yes kelly we
are rocking with an underdog prop
i found two underdogs that are uh
they're somewhat dogs they're somewhat
dogs
the prop isn't over though kelly the
prop isn't over so
don't be alarmed the prop isn't over
we're gonna go with over
one and a half receptions but i need the
audience to
help me out here we got two options we
got
scotty miller or we got demarcus
robinson
which way should we ride get in the
comments let me know
uh kelly you even know these guys are
no i actually had to google both of them
before uh
rehearsal just to make sure i wasn't
crazy yes of course i know who they both
are
greg come on uh look if you're gonna
make me pick
i'm gonna do it on purpose just because
scotty miller burned me in the packers
game that first half
uh under just for fun i'll take scottie
miller
uh over one and a half receptions that's
where i'm leaning here
we do love underdogs on this show and
demarcus robinson
and scotty mill i think they can both go
over one and a half yards depending on
you know tom brady's progressions and
then patrick mahomes progressions
what the defense shows them scotty
miller's got speed for
days and actually tyrique hill has been
asked a lot about scottie miller's speed
and i think maybe it peed him off but um
he
generally doesn't line up in the slot
but i think it's possible for both guys
uh to get um to get over the two the two
receptions i i know i should choose one
i guess maybe i'll go with i don't know
coin flip boom
scotty miller that's who i'm rocking
with
you're rocking with scotty yeah why not
all right all right i'm in the comments
then i'm in the comments
uh handy danny yo burns in the comments
shout out ver
yo doesn't he have to like go rob from
the rich
for the give to the poor or something
isn't doesn't he have things going on in
his life
to not be in our comments hey super bowl
sunday he's running
a locky town forever vern's verified i
need to get verified as well so we'll
see about that anyway moving on verified
in your
[Music]
16 is rocking with demarcus robinson he
says demarcus
uh shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh mikey draco mikey
that's not mikey locks it is mikey draco
uh
he says don't disrespect kelly scotty
sees him do not disrespect kelly we
don't
see his kelly here he's rocking with
scotty uh
kathy the comments are just flying we
are filling up these comments
today all right here we go they're just
moving so fast uh
i got them damien rivera says robinson
damien rivera says robertson kp giant
says scotty kathy the next one
i'm just going to call it all right i'm
just going to call it matter of fact
everybody i said you also are walking
away with a hoodie i just want to let
you guys know that but the next one here
we go cabbie ready
are you ready i'm ready we're ready here
we go we're scrolling
we're scrolling and we are scrolling
bam i got it i got it gabby
b royal one b royal one
and finn sanity two for one special
right here the two for one special
they both said scotty miller we are
riding with scotty keller
we are riding with scotty miller gave
the two for one special
right there you know the deal that you
get at like mcdonald's jack and you know
yeah whatever yeah two for one special i
gotta get you guys out more i swear
hey we love we love jeffy mcdonald's in
the comments by the way mcdonald's in
the comments
giving away more videos go ahead we're
rocking with scotty miller as a as our
underdog prop to get over
one and a half receptions it's gonna be
a fun game and good luck with your
wagers
make sure to check in with br betting
socials to get the link
for the odds boost for the travis kelsey
squad ride
minus 62 to plus 300 or plus 300 as g
money likes to say
and make sure you tap in with uh greg
ivory on the ig stories on br
underscore betting because it's you're
gonna have a great time
rocking with our dude in the big game
thank you so much to everybody
uh who has participated in all the squad
rides we've done 20 shows
and we really appreciate the love we
really really appreciate you guys
playing the comments
and sending incredible videos and
sharing your videos
and definitely sending all those locks
thank you very much
kevin yes i'm so sorry but the handy
dandy ipad is moving fast because the
clock
mcdonald's and i gotta give away hoodies
ob
lord you were walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go
i'm back into the comments wade zero
eight two one you're walking away with
hoodie
ryan noah kelly yeah you're walking away
with a hoodie
he shouted you out kelly uh here we go
we got nap 90 23 you walk away with a
hoodie
orange hate hat boy you're walking away
with hilly a
ballinger three three three you're
walking away with a hoodie uh cabbie i'm
just gonna keep on going okay
okay one more one matt matt
j layman you're walking away with hoodie
and cabbie said one more and i don't
like to follow rules
christopher blues christopher blues
you're walking away
there it is congratulations
thank you to our legends today uh tom
santangelo
nikki cass and spencer friedman
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is cabbie richards thank you so
much for
rocking with us all season we're going
to say peace and good luck today
in a super bowl sunday go cheese
[Music]
[Music]
you